[Music]
today's question comes from jennifer in
new york i'm a registered nurse and also
a new mom to a wonderful six-month-old
son currently i'm working my dream job
making 75 000 a year to speed up our
debt snowball i took a position as a
part-time travel nurse on the weekends
bringing home an extra 8 000
per month is that what that is but i'm
working 70 hours a week i left my dream
job for another travel nurse assignment
if i left my dream job for another
travel nurse assignment i'd make triple
my salary working just three days per
week should i leave on good terms to
raise my income accelerate the baby
steps and hope that my dream job company
will hire me back in a few years when i
don't want to do travel nursing anymore
well now you know this is a very
personal opinion here i don't know what
dave thinks but i would i would take the
opportunity now i think if you leave
well
and you explain why you're leaving
because of a very clear goal of getting
through the debt snowball and the baby
steps faster
nurses i mean we have a large amount of
nurses that have burned out and are
leaving the industry and so i don't
think that you're going to have a
problem getting back on with that
company down the line i would take the
opportunity now to knock out the baby
steps quicker
now very few companies have the policy
that we have at ramsey we almost never
rehire that's correct it uh we do but
it's very very very rare
yeah 99 of the time we don't
and uh because the reason you left is
the reason that you leave again and so
um
we don't we don't do revolving doors
around here but very few companies take
that stand
so um you know that's the thing
you got to decide you know if the if you
couldn't get back on with that company
can you find something that looks a lot
like your dream job probably and i think
the answer is yes yeah i think you can
i think you can um the only thing i'm
worried about here ken is i mean
travel nursing with a six month old yeah
but it's only three days a week so she's
tripling her salary and only working
three days a week whereas right now
she's working 70 hours a week with the
main nursing job and the travel yeah so
she's going to have more time with kiddo
triple the money speeding up the baby
steps you know look to me i'd take it
it's the opportunity to fast forward
some things and then
she's going to have a lot of options
yeah the other thing is if you get out
there
and you're miserable
you can look for a job that's correct i
mean i don't see any risk here it's not
permanent because travel nursing is
generally a temporary thing that's
correct most people don't make a career
out of that and that's part of the
industry is there's a lot of come and go
there are part of that part of the
industry
so to speak